في تطورات السياسيه اجرى رئيس الوزراء
البلجيكيه اليكساندر دكرو في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيان مشاورات مع رئيس فلودر
في مؤتمر صحفي انه طلب دعما عسكريا دوليا
اكبر لبلاده بينما ذكر ذكره في تغريده على
تويتر ان بلاده ستقدمه مساعدات انسانيه
وعسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا هذا وذكرت
الرئاسه الاخرانيه ان اعلانات
البلجيكيا الاوكرانيا المشتركا اكد دعم
تحرك اكياس للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
وحلف شمال الاطلسي
اريد دراما
بلجيكا وقد كانت من السباقين الى تجميد 50
مليون يورو من الاصول الروسيه ان لم يكن
اكثر وهذا مهم للغايه لاجبار روسيا على
تعويض الخسائر التي تسببت بها شهدنا هجمات
صاروخيه ارهابيه ونحن بحاجه الى مزيد من
الدعم وبالجيكا مستعده لدعم اوكرانيا
بمولدات الطاقه وهذا مهم جدا لصالح
المجتمعنا
بلجيكا وبولندا وليتوانيا في قمه دوليه
للحبوب دعى اليها الرئيس الاخرى
وتهدفه الى تصدير الحبوب الى الدول الاكثر
عرضه لخطر المجاعه والجفاف وقال ذلك ان
بلاده جمعت نحو 150 مليون دولار من اكثر
من 20 دوله ومن الاتحاد الاوروبي لتصدير
الحبوب لدول مثل اثيوبيا والسودان وجنوب
السودان والصومال واضاف ان اوكرانيا تعتزم
ارسال 60 سفينه على الاقل من الموانئ
الاخرانيه للدول الاكثر عرضه لخطر المجاعه
والجفاف واكد ذلك ان مبادره الحبوب منه
اوكرانيا ستكون من اكبر المساهمات في
تحقيق الاستقرار العالميه